>> Laura: WE TOLD YOU LAST
NIGHT HOW A MIKE CAUGHT
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYING HE
PLANS TO RELEASE THE HOUSE
INTEL'S CONTROVERSIAL FISA
MEMO.
KELLY IMPLIED ITS RELEASE
THEY WORK FOR ME, WORK FOR
DICING IT, LOOKING AT IT SO
WE KNOW WHAT IT MEANS AND
WHAT IT UNDERSTANDS.
>> DID YOU SEE IT.
>> DID I.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> WE'LL LET -- IT WILL BE
RELEASED HERE PRETTY QUICK,
I THINK.
>> Laura: FOX SOURCES ARE
TELLING US IT COULD BE
RELEASED TOMORROW AND ADAM
SCHIFF JUST TWEETED OUT THAT
IT'S HIS UNDERSTANDING THAT
THE MEMO THAT WAS SENT TO
THE WHITE HOUSE FOR REVIEW
WAS CHANGED SOMEHOW BY DEVIN
NUNES.
WE HAVEN'T CONFIRMED THAT
AND SO HE IS COMPLAINING
WHAT THE WHOLE COMMITTEE DID
NOT APPROVE THAT THAT JUST
WAS TWEETED A FEW MOMENTS
AGAINST THE RELEASE AS WE
SAID EARLIER ISSUING A
STATEMENT TODAY CLAIMING THE
OMISSIONS OF SOME FACTS
IMPACT THE MEMO'S ACCURACY.
YOU NEED THE FULL CONTEXT
THEY SAY.
ALAN DERSHOWITZ IN MIAMI
BEACH.
AUTHOR OF THE BEST SELLER
"TRUMPED UP" HOW
POLITICIZATION OF CRITICAL
DEMOCRACY.
AND IN ATLANTA CHRIS SMUCKER
A FORMER HEAD OF THE
INVESTIGATIVE DIVISION IN
WASHINGTON AND SOMEONE WHO
PERSONALLY KNOWS DIRECTOR
CHRISTOPHER WRAY AND SPECIAL
COUNSEL BOB MUELLER.
ALL RIGHT, PROFESSOR, LET'S
START WITH YOU HERE.
THERE SEEMS TO BE THESE
DUELING LEAKS COMING OUT
TODAY.
SOME LEAKS OF INFORMATION
THE EMAILS THAT WERE FOUND,
THE ADDITIONAL EMAILS IN THE
FALL OF 2016.
BUT, FOR THE MOMENT, LET'S
FOCUS ON THE RELEASE OF THIS
MEMO.
GIVEN WHAT WE KNOW NOW, DO
YOU BELIEVE THIS MEMO SHOULD
BE RELEASED, SHOULD SEE THE
LIGHT OF DAY?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND ALSO THE CONTEXT SHOULD
LET THE PUBLIC DECIDE.
LET'S SEE THE MEMO.
IF PEOPLE IN THE FBI THINK
IT'S OUT OF CONTEXT, LET
MATERIAL IN CONTEXT AND LET
THE PEOPLE DECIDE.
AS FAR AS THE STRZOK ISSUE
IS CONCERNED, IT SHOWS WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN THE FBI DOESN'T
HAVE A CLEAR RULE THAT SAYS
TO SAY INDICTMENT, NO
INDICTMENT, ESPECIALLY
DURING AN ELECTION.
IF IN FACT STRZOK TRIED TO
DELAY IT, IT PROBABLY BACK
FIRED BECAUSE IF IT HAD BEEN
RELEASED EARLIER, THEN MAYBE
THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
DECIDE THERE WERE NO MORE
CLASSIFIED MATERIAL AND THEY
WOULD HAVE CORRECTED IT
EARLIER.
EVER HAPPEN.
AND WE HAVE TO HAVE RULES
PREVENTING IT FROM EVER
HAPPENING AGAIN.
>> Laura: CHRIS, YOU KNOW
MUELLER.
YOU KNOW WRAY.
CHRISTOPHER WRAY UNDER SOME
FIRE ALTHOUGH HE WAS, YOU
CONFIRMATION AS HEAD OF THE
IS GOING TONIGHT?
>> WELL, AS JOHN Q. CITIZEN
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE THE
FISA COURT WAS MISLEAD.
I WOULD LOVE TO KNOW IF THE
FISA JUDGE WAS AWARE THAT IF
THE DOSSIER INFORMATION WAS
INCLUDED THAT IT WAS PAID
FOR BY A POLITICAL OPPONENT.
BUT THE FBI EXECUTIVE IN ME
OR FORMER EXECUTIVE IN ME
SAYS LET'S PLAY BY THE
RULES.
NOT LIKE THIS.
THIS IS NOT HOW YOU RELEASE
INFORMATION FROM A PARTISAN
BODY LIKE CONGRESS.
I JUST DON'T HAVE ANY FAITH
IN CONGRESSIONAL COMMITTEES.
I'M SORRY.
THEY'VE GOT THEIR OWN AGENDA
AND THERE'S A PROCESS FOR
RELEASING FISA INFORMATION.
I'VE USED IT.
IT'S NOT THAT HARD TO USE.
THERE'S A RIGHT WAY TO DO
THIS, AND I JUST LIKE TO SEE
IT DONE BY THE RULES.
YOU GET IN TROUBLE WHEN YOU
START MAKING UP YOUR OWN
RULES.
>> Laura: WELL, WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN THE FBI MAKES UP ITS
OWN RULES.
>> I HAVE TO TELL YOU.
>> Laura: WHO IS SUPPOSED TO
DO OVERSIGHT OF THE FBI.
>> I HAVE TO TELL YOU.
>> Laura: CHRIS DOES
OVERSIGHT AT THE FBI.
IF THERE WAS A POLITICAL
ANIMUS AS PROFESSOR
DERSHOWITZ HAS TALKED ABOUT
ON THIS SHOW SO OFTEN
APPLICATION ITSELF WE HAVE A
REAL PROBLEM ON OUR HANDS
POLITICIZING LAW ENFORCEMENT
IN THE UNITED STATES.
I'M A HUGE DEFENDER OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
YOU HAVE A BALANCING ACT.
FOLLOW THE RULES.
WHAT IF THE FINN WASN'T
FOLLOWING THE RULES AND THEY
WERE OFF HALF COCKED,
PROFESSOR?
>> UM-HUH.
IT'S SO REFRESHING TO HEAR
CONSERVATIVES AND
REPUBLICANS QUESTIONING AND
OVERSEEING THE FBI.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
LIBERALS DID FOR YEARS AND
YEARS AND YEARS.
ENFORCEMENT.
CONSERVATIVES ARE SAYING
WELL, WE NEED TRANSPARENCY.
WE NEED ACCOUNTABILITY.
LOOK, EVERYBODY SHOULD BE IN
PEOPLE CLAIM NATIONAL
SECURITY NEEDS CENSORSHIP,
WHEN IT ULTIMATELY GETS
RELEASED, IT WAS NOT REALLY
SO IMPORTANT.
OBVIOUSLY THE PENTAGON
PAPERS MAKES THAT POINT.
THE GOVERNMENT GOT UP IN
FRONT OF THE SUPREME COURT
AND SAID THE COUNTRY WOULD
FALL IF THE PENTAGON PAPERS
WERE RELEASED AND THEY WERE
RELEASED AND OF COURSE ONLY
POSITIVE CAME FROM IT.
IN GENERAL I'M IN FAVOR OF
FOLLOW THE RULES.
BUT THE RULES OUGHT TO ERROR
ON THE SIDE OF DISCLOSURE
RATHER THAN SUPPRESSION.
>> Laura: JUST FOR
DISCLOSURE ADAM SCHIFF'S
TWEET SENT OUT DISCOVERED
LATE TONIGHT THAT CHAIRMAN
NUNES MADE MATERIAL CHANGES
CHANGES NOT APPROVED BY THE
COMMITTEE.
WHITE HOUSE, THEREFORE,
FOR RYE
FOR RELEASE.
SO, CHRIS, YOU CAN CLOSE IT
OUT.
BUT, YOU KNOW, YOU
IT DID OR NOT, WELL, YOU
CAN'T MATERIALLY CHANGE A
DOCUMENT THAT THE COMMITTEE
HASN'T APPROVED.
WE HAVE TO LEARN MORE ABOUT
THAT.
CHRIS, YOU KNOW MUELLER, YOU
KNOW WRAY.
YOU ALSO KNOW THE FACTS AS
THEY HAVE DEVELOPED ABOUT
THE AGENTS AND THE PETER
STRZOK DOING BOTH
INVESTIGATIONS AND EMAIL AND
TRUMP.
YOU HAVE OUTCOME
YOU HAVE CUTCOME
YOU HAVE CONCOME
YOU HAVE CONFIME
YOU HAVE CONFIDENCE IN THE
OUTCOME OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
>> I DO HAVE CONFIDENCE IN
THE OUTCOME.
I KNOW CHRISTOPHER WRAY.
HE DESERVES THE BENEFIT OF
THE DOUBT UNDER THESE
CIRCUMSTANCES I'M ALL FOR
THEY CAN TAKE CRITICISM.
THEY SHOULD BE TRANSPARENT.
HE WAS APPROVED WITH THE
OVERWHELMING VOTE OF THE
SENATE.
LET'S GIVE HIM THE
CONFIDENCE.
CREDIBILITY AND GO WITH HIS
RECOMMENDATION AT THIS POINT
AND LET'S DO IT RIGHT.
IF THERE IS MISCONDUCT THERE
LET'S REFER THAT TO THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL.
>> Laura: YOU KEEP SAYING
LET'S DO IT RIGHT.
THEY ARE DOING IT RIGHT.
YOU ACT AS IF I'M PUTTING
ASIDE THIS TWEET BY SCHIFF,
THEY HAVE DONE IT RIGHT.
KRONCKE, PROFESSOR, THEY
WENT THROUGH THE PROCESS OF
THE COMMITTEE, REVIEWING
THIS DOCUMENT, REVIEWING ITS
CONTENTS FOR NATIONAL
SECURITY CONCERNS, CHIEF OF
STAFF, THE PRESIDENT, OTHER
WRAY AND NOW FBI OFFICIALS
SAY NO, THIS IS AN ISSUE OF
YOU KEEP SAYING DO IT BY THE
RULES.
I THINK THEY HAVE FOLLOWED
THE RULES.
AGAIN, SETTING ASIDE THIS
TWEET THAT WE CAN'T CONFIRM.
PROFESSOR, FINAL THOUGHTS?
>> CONSTITUTIONALLY THE
PRESIDENT HAS THE AUTHORITY
TO DECLASSIFY ANYTHING.
>> Laura: RIGHT.
>> HE IS THE ULTIMATE
AUTHORITY ON WHAT CAN BE
DECLASSIFIED.
AND IF HE WANTS TO SEE THE